- I love how open you
are about mental health
because I have similar issues
and I've suffered from depression.
And I think a lot of people,
especially in the creative
world or just from childhood,
you've been kind of trained to
just keep going and you can handle it,
and especially as a woman, it's like,
"Don't let them see you
sweat," like, you know?
So I just love that you're open about that
because not everybody's as
vulnerable at being like that,
and I think it's helpful for your fans.
'Cause I know in every meet and greet
you probably get people
saying that, I do too,
and they're like, "Man, thank you for just
"being open in your
songs and open, you know,
"with everybody 'cause I
felt like this was just me,
"and knowing that somebody
else is going through it
"makes you not feel alone
and so depressed about it."
So thank you for doing that.
It's really hard.
- I just have to say that
you were the first idol
that I ever had and-
- You are so sweet.
- I wouldn't be the artist,
or even the person, that I am
with being so outspoken,
and vulnerable, and fearless
if I hadn't had you to look up to.
So I thank you for that because-
- Well you're very nice.
- Yes, I just like, I looked
at you as my idol growing up.
You are fearless, and
courageous, and real as-
You know?
- Yep.
- And I love that about you,
and I've always just thought to myself,
when I was younger I
always thought to myself,
"If I ever make it I wanna be like her,
"because she's real,
and she's genuine," and-
- Well, and I think the
thing about it, though,
is even you're saying like, you know,
"You're strong, you're courageous,
you're all those things,"
I'm not all the time!
It takes work.
That's the thing I think
everybody looks at us
as like even when you overcome
something they're like,
"Okay, she's already overcome that."
I'm like, "No, no, no,
that's a daily effort
"in trying to be positive."
That's a daily effort
and that's not a given,
like you're just over it and you went
to some magical therapy session
and it's over.
- Right.
I think that that's a daily
thing that you work at,
and a daily thing that I
work at, and I don't know.
Thank you for the compliments,
but I just think it's really,
it's a really cool thing,
and it's not easy to always
have a spotlight on you
and arrows being aimed at you,
especially when you are vulnerable
and you give people more ammo
for all the trolls out there.
So, anyway, but thank you for doing that.